Something interesting happened and I believe it was not too long after about 2000
is that the term fuzzing took on another connotation and in this connotation,
fuzzing basically penetration testing, and what I mean by that is fuzzing is used for very specific
purpose which is finding security vulnerabilities in applications.
And usually the connotation is--is that the fuzzing is being done
on applications that the person doing the fuzzing didn't write.
So for example what we might do is find some sort of a machine on the Internet that offers a service
and we'll do random testing over the Internet of that service with the goal of finding bugs in the
service that are going to let us mount an attack such as a denial of service or some sort of an
exploitable vulnerability that will let us mount an intrusion on that Internet service.
The sort of an interesting thing about this newer connotation of fuzzing is really gotten rather big.
So for an example, plenty of special purpose tools are available both commercial
and open source for performing fuzzing over the network.
The best of these contains a lot of canned knowledge about protocols due to a lot of
relatively unskilled user to find bugs in services that are available over the network.